[Music]
portland burns
as peaceful protesting returns is it a
liberal run locale or a deep circle in
hell
it's getting hard to tell yeah the city
of roses keeps smelling like smoke
because their leaders are an absolute
joke boy this is like a long poem
portland cops declared a riot last night
as they arrested people for smashing
windows lighting fires and throwing
frozen
water bottles eggs and even metal road
spikes at officers
to mark the one year anniversary of
george floyd's death
although it also coincided with their
previously scheduled nightly riot
all done peacefully of course by
peaceful activists who were peacefully
active
did i mention it was peaceful police say
about 200 people gathered outside the
multnomah county justice center some
spread
graffiti some shouted burn it down some
lit a dumpster on fire
why are they always so mad at dumpsters
they made quite a mess
or as msnbc called it a brilliant piece
of performance art that should be
nominated for nobel prize
the crowd later marched to city hall and
smashed some of its windows or as cnn is
reporting
they kindly volunteered to renovate the
building to increase airflow and make it
more covent safe
stick around for when they rip the doors
off to make it handicapped accessible
all right tyrus why don't you think this
happens where you live
why is it portland uh because big man
walks with
big gun because we
we get it uh unfortunately and we don't
we call things what they are in
the adult world there's nothing protest
or peaceful about this this is ryan this
makes zero sense i
couldn't have been happier with the
outcome of george floyd we saw progress
we saw
a police officer being held accountable
so on the anniversary
you would celebrate one his life if
if it was important to you and two that
we saw
a major moment in justice in this
country
so why burned it down when you got what
we
wanted we wanted accountability we
wanted a fair trial we didn't want the
jurors to give the benefit of the doubt
just because they were a law officer
literally you got everything you asked
for
and then you still tried to burn it down
the system doesn't work
police officers in jail forever yeah
like
we were we got it but that's not what
it's about it has nothing to do with
george floyd
sounds nice when they report it it
sounds nice when we have to say peaceful
pro
nah these are thugs and looters who are
looking for an excuse to burn things
down because they don't want to work
they just want and they're a lot they've
been allowed to do it that's the thing
it's the lack of accountability like if
i were young
and i knew that i could go out every
night and just
up you know i i i don't know what
young greg gutfeld would do but i don't
think he'd be sitting at home
no no absolutely not and neither would
young chris barron yeah by the way
why don't we just give them what they
want look they
they want anarchy i'm willing to give up
the border wall
if we build a wall around portland and
just say
have at it we're done police are out you
want this
you've got it yeah that would be nice
that would last
one week they would eat each other
decide to film it dr sapphire and turn
it into a tv show
instead of olympics it's called like
antifa versus
society they had one it was called
portlandia it's just now like
it looks like sons of anarchy so they
can just revamp landia to give a
realistic portrayal of what it is
but it's a state of chaos uh mixed with
this homeless epidemic and they're
getting huge federal funds to fix it
yeah where's that going yeah that's true
you know kat i believe that this
is a cause of like an outsized
self-esteem movement
meeting this lack of accountability so
you have people who believe they can do
whatever they want just destroying
things because they can't themselves
achieve
anything of merit what do you say to
that theory ms
timf if that's your real name it is okay
um but i also yeah i agree i also think
that
it's awesome how the mayor was just so
concerned
about making all these concessions to
them like listen i know where you're
coming from and they all just started
screaming
like you're like it's not that
complicated like what do they want what
do they want they have what they want
what they want is to set things on fire
right exactly exactly yeah but it
it's like the mayor and all these
democrats thought it was going to end
with
trump tyrus's point it had nothing to do
with trump never had
never had it's like they fed the
crocodile and now the crocodile is even
hungrier it wants to eat
everybody and you sprinkle a little
social justice virtue and
they're doing it for the good fight we
won the fight we knocked him out in the
first round yeah
we go imagine if i was hey it's martin
luther king day i'm going to burn down
the building
what the hell all right hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else